merci cher eric de m'avoir proposé de
d'ouvrir avec toi cette cette matinée
cette journée de travail j'imagine que
si cela m'a été proposé c'est parce que
effectivement nicolas sarkozy m'avait
confié après michèle alliot-marie la
responsabilité de la protection la
coordination de la protection de nos
concitoyens et je retrouve bien sûr un
certain nombre de visages amis chacun
comprend pas que je suis plus
particulièrement guillaume larrivé
aujourd'hui député de l'yonne et
spécialiste de plus en plus reconnu et
ce n'est pas fini de ses sujets et qui a
été à mon cabinet comme directeur
adjoint se re défi de la sécurité
bien sûr c'est un défi qui est
indispensable à relever mais c'est vrai
qu'il est extrêmement difficile car je
pense que derrière derrière l'épiderme
des mots finalement ne reste
heureusement d'ailleurs que les actes et
les résultats et ça doit être l'occasion
pour nous cette matinée comme et
rivières denis invité d'abord de
commencer par rétabli ou rappeler
quelques quelques vérités de se souvenir
des faits et bien sûr d'imaginer des
solutions concrètes des solutions
concrètes et parfois inédites parce que
la situation est aujourd'hui en grande
partie est inédite
mais il faut avoir le temps
naturellement de se souvenir et la
mémoire je crois reste le meilleur outil
de l'action et cp mois nous permet de
dire à quel point d'abord nous devons et
nous pouvons être fiers de ce qui a été
accompli en matière de sécurité de lutte
contre la délinquance d'abord pendant le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy il y à
une réalité qui n'est d'ailleurs à vrai
dire pas tellement contesté et
heureusement parce que c'est une vérité
c'est que la délinquance non seulement
n'a pas augmenté mais dans un certain
nombre de domaines
elle a même diminué et sans doute cela
s'explique
l'alchimie de raisonner parce que nous
n'y avions une politique et des
principes qui était à la fois
très fermes et très clairs il y avait un
principe avec lequel personne sous son
autorité n'a transiger c'est que les
droits de la victime doivent toujours
toujours passer avant ce dédain des
délinquants alors cette vérité c'est pas
moi qui vous le dis c'est que il ya ici
un certain nombre de spécialistes et
quissac on fait souvent référence à un
observatoire l'observatoire national de
la délinquance et de la réponse pénale
qui est un organisme je le rappelle qui
est un organisme indépendant qui
d'ailleurs m'a profondément agacé à
quelques reprises pendant que j'exerçais
ses fonctions mais il ne reste pas moins
que cette indépendance est aujourd'hui
une garantie aussi de ce que je vais
vous dire d'une exactitude de ce que je
vais vous dire et selon cet observatoire
entre 2005 et 2011 le nombre de vols a
baissé de 11 et demi pour cent le nombre
de personnes victimes de vols avec
violence a diminué de 5% et les
violences crapuleuses physique donc ont
elles aussi reculé de 5%
est-ce que c'est suffisant non mais
enfin c'est quand même intéressant à
noter parce que si ça avait été l
inverse naturellement qu'est ce que
n'aurait pas entendu mais c'est pas
suffisant et en matière si et de
sécurité cela ne l'est d'ailleurs jamais
surtout dans une société caractérisée
par une violence de plus en plus
prégnante où les délinquants sont de
plus en plus imaginatifs sont de plus en
plus déterminés et j'allais dire de plus
en plus agressif je pense à la
délinquance des mineurs
il n'y a pas une explosion en matière de
de délinquance des mineurs quantitative
mais il y à une explosion de la violence
des mineurs qui sont mises en causes et
ses résultats qui étaient des résultats
très encourageants sont le fruit d'un
signal d'une très grande fermeté qui
avaient été adressées dès le départ vrai
dire dès 2002 par nicolas sarkozy alors
ministre de l'intérieur aux délinquants
et criminels et le développement
considérable de la vidéoprotection ne
pas insister sur ce sujet mais la
vidéoprotection au départ il n'y avait
que les communes qui étaient gérés par
don par la droite qui réclamait la
vidéoprotection et puis les hôtes ont
été obligés de faire un espèce de
volte-face idéologique et se se sont mis
à réclamer eux mêmes cette vidéo
protection est vrai dire j'étais sur ce
plan a pas ministre nater très heureux
parce que les subventions qu'ils étaient
délivrés dans le cas du fpi pdci était
organiste qui donnait ses subventions
aller plutôt vers des communes de gauche
et j'avais dû me tourner à l'époque vers
guillaume envers d'autant dire listeria
sens pour moi c'est que des communes de
gauche il faut dire qu'à l'époque y en
avait plus qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
premier élément mais ce n'était pas le
seul
parce qu'il s'y était mis extrêmement
tardive et donc pardon quand on parle de
l'es12 des idées nous avons été
incontestablement beaucoup plus à
l'anticipation sur l' attente de nos
concitoyens que ne l'a été la gauche
avec une espèce de carcans idéologiques
qui l'en empêchaient donc c'est la
vidéoprotection si on oublie
généralement de lire l'augmentation du
budget de la justice et la mise en place
d'un certain nombre de mesures les
peines planchers j'imagine que georges
il reviendra est tout à l'heure de la
rétention de sûreté qui étaient autant
d'armes qui fondent et quoi qu'ils
fondaient tout simplement ce qui est
indispensable à notre société c'est à
dire qu'ils font d'elle la puissance de
l'état et qui garantisse et donc un
meilleur respect de l'ordre public alors
c'est vrai que on allait les opposants
la majorité socialiste ont essayé de de
dénigrer de déformer de caricaturer et
ils perçoivent ans et est aujourd'hui la
très grande différence entre ce que nous
étions parvenus à obtenir
est ce que peine véritablement à
réaliser est la preuve
là aussi je le dise couvert d'un certain
d'entre vous sous couvert de bruno
beschizza
la preuve c'est ce qui s'est passé à
quelques jours à peine puisqu'il y a eu
sous les fenêtres de la ministre de la
justice
chacun sait toute l'affection qu'on lui
porte et j'espère qu'on va pas la
retirer
et bien saoulé venait de la ministre la
justice s'est produit ce qui ne s'était
pas déroulé depuis 33 ans
c'est à dire une manifestation de cette
nature place vendôme 33 ans s'y passe
toujours en des comptes mettant trois
ans et plus qu'une génération et ils ont
réussi cet exploit de conduire les
policiers devant la chancellerie
il ya un deuxième ce fait qui est lié à
cela c'est que c'est la première fois
aussi je crois bruno depuis 2000-2001
qu'il y a eu un front uni de la totalité
des syndicats
j'avais des syndicats la police on n'a
pas dit combien de temps j'avais moi
pour parler parce que doit se tenir un
bon moment mais les syndicats de police
j'ai été rapidement ministre des
affaires sociales et du travail
joyet les syndicats à l'époque je voyais
bernard thibault la cgt tous joaillier
des gens qui étaient là monf est
représenté 5 6 ans le meilleur des cas 8
% des salariés
quand vous recevez des syndicats de
policiers ces 85 % du monde policier 85%
et donc là la totalité des syndicats des
syndicats de gardiens
jusqu aux commissaires se sont unis pour
manifester en réalité un dégoût de la
politique pénale qui est menée
aujourd'hui qui est totalement
décourageante et donc c'était un signal
extrêmement fort qui a été aussi adressé
au gouvernement sur sa politique alors
comme le répétait charles pasqua parce
que je pense qu'on peut pas faire de
réunion sans sont cités
faire une référence à charles pasqua
charles pasqua beaucoup d'entre vous
aussi locaux connus côtoyé il est
toujours les faits les commentaires sont
libres mais les faits sont têtus
alors c'est un verger écrit et dans
l'autre sens de l'insee c'était l'un
vertement tout cas c'était ça et c'est
vrai que les faits sont têtus
parce que depuis l'élection de françois
hollande en 2012
la délinquance s'est remise à augmenter
il y a eu une inversion et il n'y a pas
un organise pas un observateur un qui
n'est pas obligé de reconnaître qu'à il
a rompu la dynamique de la baisse de la
délinquance que l'on avait réussi à
installer
j'ai pris 2 mai 2005 a mis six ans
étaient ces deux depuis 2002 et jusqu'en
et si vous regardez bien en trois ans on
observe une détérioration sur les trois
grands sujets les atteintes aux biens
qui augmente manière très sensible je
vous rappelle ce chiffre qui m'a frappé
c'est 78 cambriolages de plus chaque
jour par rapport à ce qui était le cas
avant 2012
78 en plus les appeler les atteintes aux
biens
les infractions économiques et
financières et les violences aux
personnes
je ne sais pas pourquoi dire je n'ai pas
réécrit sais c'est pas surhumain sur ma
note mais les violences aux personnes
c'est ce qui frappe le plus c'est une
tendance lourde de nos sociétés c'est
vrai qu'on a du mal à les bloquer et on
n'avait pas réussi sur cet aspect là
totalement inversé mais on avait réussi
à contenir et là en fait ça augmente
mécaniquement inexorablement
inéluctablement d'année en année et donc
sur les trois grands sujets les
infractions économiques et financières
les violences aux personnes et les
atteintes aux biens
il y à une détérioration depuis 2009
et alors j'allais dire comme par hasard
il y avait d'autres réseaux mais en face
le hasard fait bien les choses
le gouvernement a décidé de changer le
thermomètre les méthodes de calcul ont
changé il y avait des raisons à ça mais
c'est un hasard qui naturellement les
arrange bien
et malgré cela malgré ces nous ces
nouvelles méthodes de calcul et bien les
faits là aussi apparaissent très
clairement et les résultats apparaissent
très clairement le mois dernier le
nouvel indicateur qui s'appelle
statistique ministériel de la sécurité
intérieure montre une hausse en un mois
des vols avec violence très sensible
plus de 10% des pas peindre pendant un
mois ce serait pas intéressant ce prono
assez sur le trimestre plus de 10%
même chose pour les cambriolages + 3 %
les vols de voiture quasiment la même
chose et je pourrai égrainé comme ça
toute la liste quand vous observez kylie
a systématiquement une augmentation et
les français à juste titre se sentent de
moins en moins en sécurité et il y a
d'ailleurs une bonne raison c'est que
jamais jamais m'entendais bien dans
notre pays il n'y a eu autant
d'agressions c'est 500 milles en 2014 et
ses résultats tailleurs sont pas mauvais
ils sont un été catastrophique
et alors les longs discours les grandes
paroles les coups de menton et manuel
valls est le grand spécialiste de ces
sujets la république n'acceptera pas
nous ne laisserons pas nous
n'abandonnerons pas et au bon moment
tant de menton bas mais ça ça ne cache
pas la très grande faiblesse des actes
est la cause principale en a plusieurs
mais la cause principale de cette des
grottes de cette dégradation
elle est clairement identifié c'est le
désarmement aussi méthodique idéologique
de notre arsenal pénal orchestrée par
christiane taubira et c'est désarmement
pénale à de très grandes très grave très
lourdes conséquences et que nous aurons
le devoir de réparer le moment venu à
vrai dire sans délai
je pense à la suppression des peines
planchers les récidives issa signifie
que les récidivistes ne sont plus
automatiquement condamné à des peines
plus lourdes même chose récidiviste que
primo délinquants pourquoi les avoir
supprimées si ce n'est par pure
idéologie ou par esprit partisan
disparition de la rétention de sûreté
il est donc impossible avec cette
politique de conserver un criminel en
prison une fois sa peine terminée même
si celui ci continue à représenter un
risque important pour notre société
troisième exemple les peines avec sursis
ne sont plus automatiquement révoqué
transformée en prison ferme
lorsqu'il ya récidive c'est ce que nous
avions mis en place et la réforme pénale
c'est août 2014 est fort pénale nous
créer une situation où la libération des
condamnés est quasi automatique des les
deux tiers de leur peine effectuée quasi
automatique et comment peut-on tolérer
que cette même réforme permette à des
délinquants condamnés jusqu'à cinq
années de prison
je vous rappelle que la justice est
rendue au nom du peuple français et de
ne pas comment permettre
comment comprendre que l'on n'exerce pas
potentiellement une seule journée de
prison lorsqu'on est condamnée jusqu'à
cinq ans vous en doutez on peut pas être
condamné à cinq années de prison pour un
vol de pommes à l'état l'âge de
l'épicier tunisien du coin non ce sont
des tentes dire qu'ils sont graves
ça peut dans un certain cas est un
prédit la situation d'un prédicateur
guillaume larrivé l'avait évoqué avant
nos propositions
cela peut être
des crimes sexuels ou tentatives de
crimes sexuels
ce sont des actes qui sont graves et
jusqu'à 5 ans potentiellement vous avez
la possibilité de ne pas passer une
seule journée sur les soul et bo
et comme si ça ne suffisait pas
d'ailleurs on nous attendons désormais
que christiane taubira se prononce en
faveur de la suppression des tribunaux
correctionnels pour mina et tout cela
aboutit à une situation où le nombre de
détenus baisse il a baissé de 2% entre
2014 et 2015 dans un contexte où les
chiffres de la criminalité eux continué
à augmenter la réalité très simple plus
de délinquants dans les rues moins de
délinquants dans les prisons ici nous ne
sommes plus dans le contingent oudalle
conjoncture
nous sommes dans le cadre d'une
véritable volonté politique de
libération des délinquants et par
laquelle il faut rappeler avec force
pour une fois que ce gouvernement donne
le sentiment et ce n'est pas une
sentiment c'est une réalité que l'on
place le délinquant trop souvent avant
la victime avant la victime mais aussi
avant la situation de ceux qui ont la
responsabilité de protéger les policiers
les gendarmes et les autres alors avant
de laisser la parole à à odile deux
intervenants que je remercie les mots si
naturellement de leur présence leurs
engagements j'aurai terminé en ajoutant
un point peut-être plus plus politique
le défi de la protection de nos
concitoyens reste l'un de ceux sans
doute de noix la manière la plus
flagrante la plus évidente la plus
visible
il y a une vraie différence entre la
droite et la gauche
c'est sans doute dans ce domaine il y en
a beaucoup d'autres mais c'est dans
doute dans ce domaine où ça apparaît aux
yeux de nos concitoyens comme la manière
plus claire eux ils ont la culture de
l'excusé nous avons la culture de la
responsabilité
eux ils récusent
la soi disant politique du chiffre nous
nous revendiquons la politique du
résultat
eux ils placent la prévention avant tout
nous nous affirmons que la première des
préventions et la certitude de la
sanction
euh déclame que la société doit être
juste et nous nous avons la conviction
que sans ordre une société ne peut être
qu'un juste alors c'est pour ça que je
suis heureux qu'on puisse profiter de
cette matinée comme nous l'avons fait
pour l'immigration comme nous l'avons
fait pour le code du travail même si
l'actualité de la semaine sur autour du
code du travail a fait que s'est
malheureusement passé un peu moins de
manière un peu moins visible qu'on
aurait vu qu'on l'aurait aimée et
surtout qu'on l'aurait mérité et bien
profitons donc de cette matinée avant je
croise celle qui sera consacrée aux
territoires ruraux à la ruralité et et à
l'agriculture donc à cet ensemble un
profitons de cette matinée pour analyser
pour tracer pour imaginer de nouvelles
solutions avec deux objectifs très
simple renforcer la protection de nos
concitoyens et réussir l'alternance
donc on travaille à vous et belle
matinée